madam grant i'm thrilled to welcome
raydalio and ariana huffington to talk
about
principles you let me start by saying
ray congratulations
just launched yeah and it's hot
it's great a lot of people make good
comments about it so we're excited
it's been exciting to see the buzz as
people start to hold up a mirror and
understand their own personalities and
some of their colleagues personalities
too
what have you liked most about creating
principles you compared to all the other
personality assessments that you've
done well i started about
25 years ago with all different tests
and
you know each one of them gives a
different dimension we did
myers-briggs and enneagram and
workplace inventory and a bunch and uh
they would all give a picture and they
were all enlightening in some ways but i
wanted to bring them all together
or create a more complete picture uh
and then i turn to you and
the the reason i wanted to do that is
because i found over those
25 years that people understanding
themselves how they
thought helped their personal
development and i found
that how they would understand each
other uh
through those various perspectives was
important
and then we could build teams and so um
i wanted to do that i'm
at a stage in my life where i just want
to pass along the things that
mattered most uh helped me most and so
then i called you and
brian little and john golden and here we
go
well i love that you wanted to make it
freely available to anybody to take it
and to also take it with their friends
and colleagues and maybe even family
members
i also i got such a kick out of taking
this assessment that i helped to design
because it opened my eyes to aspects of
my personality
that i had not seen before and the
combination of the rigor and then the
practical insights for me has
has led to some great conversations
already and ariana
you have gone through the assessment i'm
curious about
what you saw and whether you've taken it
to your team yet
absolutely i love taking it and not only
have
we taken it to my team at thrive but we
use it
with all um candidates
who make it to the front of the line
the two or three finalists that we
normally have take
the assessment and
what i love is how unexpected it is
i don't think you can trick it because
you are asked the question thank you
adam for being
so ingenious here you ask often the same
question in so many different ways
and some of the key um
insights for me were um
the opportunity to show how much can you
put things in perspective
like are you somebody who is overwhelmed
by mistakes
who will do anything rather than risk
making mistakes
are you somebody who sees mistakes as
just part of the creative process
and being willing to uh fail along the
way
for me that was one of the key insights
and and and you were asked that question
again
and again in many many different ways
which i absolutely loved
and then the whole
distinction between who
is more comfortable with philosophical
and abstract
discussions or deliberations and who
wants everything to be very
um hardcore detailed rigorous and
it's interesting here the differences
between us and you know
adam you are like absolutely rigorous
and i think ray and i are more willing
to be
what some might describe head in the
clouds
but knowing that um among colleagues is
so key
and also for me it's knowing what do i
need
um to help me to basically
complement skills that i don't have as
naturally
like being incredibly organized and
detail-based i wish i could show you my
floor
which is thrown with papers which i wish
i had somebody here in my home in lake
who could organize into
files but i've never taken the time to
do that
so that was just another small insight
that is key as you are building teams
well ray one of the things that that you
brought to the table as we were building
this assessment was
not only the dimensions of personality
we normally study but also the ones that
you've discovered are important through
your experience building and running
bridgewater and i know that one of the
things you've done with with principles
you is
you've looked at your own strengths and
said just like ariana's highlighting
well how do i find people who are going
to bring things that i lack
any examples or stories stand out to
bring that to life
well yeah i mean i
i'm like ariana well i hope we'll turn
to our tests at some point
unlike ariana in terms of uh you know
the big picture
and the conceptual and so on and on uh
disorganized i create compensating
mechanisms
but if i'm not working with somebody who
even tells me
you know what comes next in my life uh
and helps to be organized you know i'm
in trouble
and and the kick that i've watched with
these uh
new ones that are coming out is how
couples
um in relationships are uh not only
taking them
themselves but watching how uh when they
put them in the process so they this
machine has got
these two profiles of them and then
i watched the conversations about what
they're each like and that's been
uh a kick so the relationships yeah
ariana said it very well we each see
things in our own way and we're blind to
the other ways and
once we realize that then we can put
together good teams and
have complementary relationships it's
meant for
us it's been one of the big fundamental
underpinnings of whatever success we've
had well doing this in couples i think
this is the first assessment i've ever
done where i don't want to slap a
don't try this at home warning label on
it
i think we should take a look at our
scores so ariana you were talking about
how we're similar and different ray
alluded to that as well
we we actually have a comparison which
everyone should be able to see now
this is just a sample so principles u
goes through 17 different traits
we've just drawn five here and you can
see ariana with the purple background
ray with the blue background and me with
the yellow background
i found this eye opening looking at it
uh it was first of all it was very
affirming to find out that we're all
creative people which must be why we
like hanging out together
but then some of these differences
crystallize things that i have not
understood
when sometimes we've miscommunicated
sometimes we've had
struggles collaborating and i wanted to
talk about a few of those i have to
start at the bottom
am i going to be the only person making
jokes today
but you'll lead the way yes we'll try
and catch up but clearly we want adam
you have such a
lead on us you take yourself so
seriously i
i feel like i have to balance that out a
little bit no
um i thought one of the the most
interesting differences here
was uh in our tendencies to be
deliberative uh
i ray i think we've had so many
discussions where
uh i've i've said look here's what 25 or
30 years of
randomized controlled experiments and
longitudinal studies show
and you just say well that's not my
intuition and i've never
understood why we disagree until i see
this pattern
tell me tell me where you're coming from
in those moments
well you know as um i've had
also 25 years of uh putting people into
jobs
and matching them up and and you know
there's an intuitive
um conceptualization where you know
or at least i feel it's not right and
that's why i find triangulating with you
is such a great way our conversations
were really
um you know how do we get at the
evidence
of relative to the ins the intuition
so uh yeah it's um it's been that kind
of perspective
that it was fun um you would be very
very um
statistical and uh while i wanted the
statistics
um like i knew uh when i was putting
together groups it just didn't seem to
work that way
oh my god i have to give you an example
of that because adam and i
have the the same differences and we
have a mutual friend
who lost her husband and the way we
dealt with her
shows this adam would bring data to her
and research that shows
what percentage of widows went back and
found love again
and rebuilt their lives and i would tell
her you know sweetheart
death doesn't really exist you know
there is an afterlife
and we are all going to be together
again and it was like
she said we were at the two extremes of
comforting her
i i i just i kept i kept wondering
okay where where where's your evidence
ariana tell me more like
show me your proof but i i think we
balance each other out very well
and i think any time that modern science
agrees with
ancient greek wisdom we are on to
something
uh let's let's talk about being detailed
and reliable because you both scored
very low on this you both alluded to the
fact that you're disorganized and
uh i i never realized until now you are
two of the people that i hear from
frequently or
from your team saying hey can you get on
a call later this afternoon
i'm like what are you talking about i
scheduled this afternoon three and a
half weeks ago
tell me a little bit about how your
lives are organized because i think
i've often struggled with that emergent
challenge to adapt and flex when i have
a plan
well uh my the way i do it is uh i'm
like i sort of kind of know a direction
and then the best way to describe it is
how am i organized
by others you know like i have
literally i do not know what i'm going
to do two hours and there's somebody who
uh gives me a nudge or i look on on the
calendar i just know the direction that
i want to go in
so that's how it works for me ariana
what about you well that's really the
key here
once you know that about yourself and it
took me a while
to learn this about myself and to accept
that i needed support
that i needed what ray called a
compensating mechanism
otherwise i would be perpetually late
and blame it on being greek um
which which is i'm trying to be humorous
guys you know to make up for the fact
that according
uh to this or not wait a minute ariana
hold on a second according to this
you answered the questions it's your own
fault
but actually i want to explain the
humorous part
which is i think that for me it's like
i love humor but i don't feel a sense of
responsibility
to be funny and make people laugh
and i think adam you're kinder and nicer
and you feel
you want to bring people together more
through humor
and as opposed to you know if it happens
it happens but it's not like a priority
one thing i want to point out though uh
because it's interesting about our
differences and how we're compensating
um when i first started this about 25
years ago i gave it to
not this test but i started with
myers-briggs and then other tests i gave
it to 150
managers and they described i asked them
to rate it
how does it describe them and 85
of them rated it a four and a five and a
scale of
uh one to five um up until that point
um they had a lot of problems with each
other
like the big picture thinker really got
annoyed at the detail thinker and the
detail thinker got annoyed at the big
picture thinker
big picture thinker would say oh you get
stumbled up in those things you're not
seeing the big picture
detail thinker would say your head's in
the clouds you don't know where you're
going
and then we started to have an
understanding
oh i see you're one of those
and then on one of these and then
there began to have data when we had the
data and we could correlate it
with how they would perform in different
types of jobs
and different kinds of rules there was a
greater understanding of each other
and the type of understanding that we're
now talking about about putting together
a group or or a partnership
um that kind of understanding let us
realize that we
needed the other uh qualities uh
in the group and so we that was only the
point that we started to
really realize how to put to together
teams and
how to understand each other and then
even communicate with each other
differently
because uh we when we think differently
we have different
sensitivities or we're talking almost a
different language
and when we understand the other person
is speaking that kind of language
we could speak more clearly to them so
that's it was
um what we're going through now is the
we take for granted but
it didn't used to exist before we
started to uh
speak that language well ray one of the
things that i thought the team did
brilliantly was visualizing
all these traits on a spectrum right i
think so many personality tests give
people a type and they get pigeonholed
and as brian little likes to say not
even pigeons like being in holes very
much
so being able to see the nuance here is
really nice i wanted to comment on
extroversion briefly
uh i'm i'm definitely the most
introverted and also probably the only
introvert in this conversation
according to the scores and i know in an
extroverted world i've had to spend a
lot of time
learning to act out of character stretch
my comfort zone
and get comfortable on a ted stage or
teaching classes even
i wonder if either of you find yourself
stretching in the other direction
and whether you've had to learn more
introverted modes in certain situations
absolutely true for me you know like
people will say
you know shut up stop talking
you know leave space least face for
others um
you know uh i'm i'm inclined to just
dive in and talk and
i'm too much so so i have gotten a lot
of feedback that way and i
have had to make compensating and i
probably only gotten there a little bit
ariana for me it's been really
getting comfortable with um
time by myself meditating
sleeping um moments or hours of
stillness
and and what was amazing is that it is a
learned skill
so in the same way adam that you got
more comfortable
uh being extrovert and i know many
people would never guess that you were
not
intrinsically i have gotten completely
comfortable now
with being
an introvert in terms of actually even
needing that time
alone refueling and renewing and
recharging
well i think this goes to one of the
things that came out of the assessment
is we don't just get to see
our scores and compare them to each
other right there are a bunch of
insights and tips
about what commonalities we might have
how we might be able to collaborate more
effectively and
seeing this you know this simple advice
right which i hadn't thought about oh we
need to balance out our intuitive and
analytical tendencies
some of us are more deliberative some of
us are less uh we need to think a little
bit about managing our energy together
right the the two of you might prefer
more crowd time more conversation time
like just let me think and write please
get out of here why are you people still
here uh i think those those differences
are extremely helpful
i want to i want to open up some of the
audience conversation now uh we have
questions coming in if you do have
questions submit them
and i can see them in the q a tab let me
start with a question
that came in early on which is
ariana how do you determine who's going
to be good at organizing you and ray
you've had to figure this out too
do you just give them the principles you
assessment and you're done or is there
anything else you do to complete that
picture
well actually the principles assessment
is an amazing way to find out who is
detail-oriented
and make sure you don't put somebody in
the job of organizing you
who is like you because you can have a
lot of fun together and trust me i made
so many mistakes like that
of hiring people i wanted to have dinner
with
and that's a different skill set than
hiring somebody who's going to organize
my life and make sure
that things get done so that for me has
been incredible another thing
that i really want to stress is
all the questions in the assessment
around being comfortable with receiving
critical feedback
and that is sort of a key question in
terms of hiring
because compassionate directness is our
number one cultural value at thrive
and hiring people who are not
comfortable with feedback
is really one of the fastest ways to a
toxic culture
because it means people don't give
feedback or they hide it
or they're passive aggressive and
resentments and disagreements faster
ray how about you she said i couldn't
say it better
that's exactly right that's that's what
the the interviews and then
uh the it's it it's not definitive it
gets you
right there but the question and answers
that
come from that uh uh the assessments
uh really confirm almost in you know 95
of the cases confirms what uh the person
is like and
so it is so much better than job
interviews
you know uh it that you interview
somebody and yeah
you know you don't really know of them
at all it's just scientific
so it uh is just as ariana described
you can tell there is a fantastic
question here from andrea who wants to
know
is there any negative point in taking
the test like discovering my partner in
business or
marriage might not be the ideal person
for me
uh ariana oh well i don't think so at
all
because um if you let's say want to stay
with your partner in
at work or in marriage it's going to
give you a roadmap
for how to be with each other
understanding each other without
judgment um instead of our
automatic response which is to judge you
adam for
being so detail-oriented and not wanting
to plow ahead
and now that i know that let's work
together
i've never seen anybody um and this is
i've done this with
ten thousand people probably i've never
seen anybody
uh not appreciate the understanding now
it'll raise questions
and but between people that's a good
path
are you like that what does it mean how
do we get along because it's the most
fundamental thing of
how do you get along so i've never seen
anybody
not regret taking the test
yeah and i think that if you're afraid
of finding out that the person you're
collaborating with or married to
is you know is not the right person for
you you're sort of missing the point
right the point is to understand them
more clearly so that you can adapt to
each other
and try to build an effective
relationship not say okay
you know what our personalities don't
match match we need a divorce
let's go to another question here which
is
uh what is in this is from albert what's
in principles u 2.0
where do you think it can be improved
ray i'll start with you on that one
well i i think that we're going to be
dealing a lot more with interpersonal
relations
and then the collection of other data
that's actually going to confirm it
so um what will happen in 2.0
is that there's going to be evidence of
the people around you
and what they think think about you so
that you can triangulate that
with actually what the test results are
because if everybody's
saying the same thing and the results
are the same well you got
you know you know that and then what
we're really excited about
is creating a systematic way really of
building the teams
to know the nature of each person's job
the fit in that job
and then the relationships between those
people and their jobs
so that you can structurally have the
computer uh
help you build the teams that's what
we're excited about
yeah i i think that's going to be really
exciting too there's a question from dan
that i'll take quickly uh the question
is why do we use a seven-point liquor
type scale instead of six we have a
psychometrician clearly on our hands
there's a lot of debate about the ideal
scales my
my view of the data is most personality
traits are shaped like a bell curve
it's most common to be right in the
center so if you don't give people the
middle
option then you're leaving out most of
the people like on the introversion
extra virgin scale
many of us are ambiverts right we're a
little bit introverted we're a little
bit extroverted we're very comfortable
in the spotlight or
also in the background so wanted to make
sure that was captured
clearly let's go to another question
from asha reeb knowing what you know now
about your your principal's you scores
what advice would you give
to your 20 year old self
um i would tell my 20 year old self
um
that i needed support
to get organized and you know maybe when
i was 20
i couldn't afford anybody to um
to come and be with me to get me
organized but even knowing that i needed
support even if that support had to be
from myself
and would have been key
in terms of avoiding the unnecessary
stress of being disorganized you know
being disorganized
is unbelievably stressful
especially for me when you when you dump
your disorder on me thank you ariana i
love you so much
i love you adam you you have a star in
my book
and so as you know i'm very quick at
responding to you
i never miss a call or a meeting with
you
but the question is how to do that with
everybody you interact with
and so if i knew that about myself
if i knew that i needed to support
myself
i would have had a lot less stress in my
twenties
and right um i tell the uh the
twenty-year-old that
life is a journey uh in which um
it's to discover oneself and
then the corresponding fit the fit
in not only the people but the job um
and the quicker you can get to that
self-discovery and self-acceptance
and then find the fit for you uh the
better your life is going to be
we have a great question here from diana
who wants to know
what you do if logic or expertise says
one thing and your intuition says
another
and i would actually love to debate this
a little bit because i know ray and i
have very different answers to that
question and ariana maybe you can
adjudicate here
although you're probably gonna side with
ray
a meditator and because she's a
meditator and i'm a meditator
you'll probably side with me oh
everything has to be about identity
you're creating an us versus them
dichotomy
meditators non-meditators you need to be
more open-minded and hear what i have to
say
are you telling me to think again this
is ironic
think again um the
i would i there are two minds there's a
subliminal mind
and then there's an intellectual mind
and i think that
uh either of them can be misleading
and when you align them so that they
each check the other then you're
probably in good shape
and so i would say um it's not
it can't be one and it can't be the
other and that meditation
has the effect of allowing that
alignment because
when you meditate you go into your
subliminal mind
and then you it helps to achieve that
alignment
so arianna what do you think
yes and i would say that i have
collected a lot of data on the subject
and the data shows that when it comes to
people
for example hiring friendships whatever
my subliminal mind was always right
like you can look at somebody's and this
is just
data through many many many years
any time i um over
ruled my subliminal mind and said yeah
no
you don't think this person is right for
this job but look at their resume
and look you know everybody else is
giving them a strong yes
go for it it didn't work
okay so the social scientist in me wants
to say you're sampling on the dependent
variable of course what's salient to you
are the cases where you ignored your
intuition
and it was right what about the times
where you followed it and it was
wrong are those as memorable uh i have a
few other maybe pieces to add to this
one is ray i would say that
meditation is something you do not
something you are
uh and i choose to meditate through
exercise
and through reading novels and i think i
get some of the same benefits but
we could have a longer conversation
about that i was just meaning that the
um intuition comes from the subliminal
mind you know
got it and because it comes from the
subliminal mind forget how you do that
that it were the question was aligning
intuition
with uh the logic and i think if they're
aligned you have a comp and you have a
comfort
and i think that if you can do that with
also triangulation
with other people smart otherwise people
you're probably getting to the right
answer i think that's key
i think that's key because i i worry
that too many people just trust their
intuition instead of testing their
intuition
right i've watched blockbuster and
blackberry and kodak and sears
fall you know fall apart because people
trusted their intuition as opposed to
challenging it
so i think that's a that's a nice way to
reconcile our views
well well well well i think this is a
larger conversation as to
whether blockbuster and blackberry and
sears failed because they trusted their
intuition
or much more likely looked at the wrong
data
so let's discuss that at another time
over a glass of wine
but it's a little more obligated
fascinating
uh adam you know about the other tools
and ariana you do
too like the dot collector in other
words you like
data we like data um and so
this is just really kind of a first step
i mean it's a it's a breakthrough step
and it's important step
uh but when we're getting the ongoing
data of
people and when then we can build from
that that really is
great it's a rich picture what do you
think about that based on what you've
seen
adam and of course you've had a lot of
uh
contact with the dot collector too
ariana what do you think about the
connection
of using data to understand people
yeah this is this is the the sort of
principles you 2.0
step that i'm most excited about is to
say whatever whatever scores you get on
principles you
that's your self-perception and you have
to triangulate that with other people's
views of you because
they're going to see your blind spots
they're also going to see your bright
spots
right the strengths that you don't even
know that you have and i can't think of
a better way to identify those than
getting dotted regularly by people who
interact with you every day
and hold up that mirror ariana yes so we
are practicing the dot collector at
thrive
and one of the hardest things as
reynolds for our teams to overcome
was the idea that getting a red dot
you know getting negative feedback
is not just a data point it's a judgment
it's like it's a stain on your record
so getting people to be more comfortable
with critical feedback
has been a challenge and incredibly
important though
and frankly the more of that you get
the more it becomes like part of life
and part of how we interact and not like
a big
like performance review once a year that
can be devastating
well we're just about out of time in
closing i want to ask you each
as people start to get their principles
you results or compare them with their
teams
what's the one piece of advice you have
for how to make use of that information
effectively
i would say triangulate with others and
then um
speaking to others about how that you
appear
and then just try to get in sync
accepting what you're like and then
appreciating others that you can work
with
and who can help you where you're weak
and i would add there is no better time
to do it
because if there is one thing that
pandemic has taught us
is the importance of building teams
building teams
in our new hybrid world with a
combination of in-office and remote is
going to be harder and more important
than ever
and having real data about
how to best communicate with colleagues
with family is going to be key
and this is an amazing way to do it
thank you ray
and thank you adam for bringing it to
the world i
i really am convinced this is going to
make a huge difference in our lives and
in the way we work
well i'm thrilled to be part of it and
for anyone with us today who feels like
they've been languishing during the
pandemic i can't think of a better jolt
than getting some feedback on what
you're like and then comparing notes
with other people
it's a great conversation starter i hope
you enjoy it and i hope it teaches you
something new
ariana rey thank you so much for joining
us today
thank you yeah and thank you ray for
making it free
it's such a joy thank you thank you all